então voltar a começar no tópico eu
estava aqui imaginassem por exemplo o
seguinte cenário com as questões da
nossa casa e vocês conseguem com o vosso
marrom que eu acredito que eu acho que
sou um com a certeza e vocês conseguem
com o vosso marconi interagir com todos
os equipamentos e com todos os produtos
que você tem você está em nossa casa e
controlar interessa um curso unificado
informações um pouco como a gente já
consegue fazer quaisquer code ter essas
informações produtos mas sem ele fica ao
lado da computação visual associada ao
software coaching
imagine por exemplo você está no
trabalho e conseguem enviar um e mail a
uma mensagem pra nossa casa e ela
responde exatamente os produtos que
vocês tenham frigorífica com os produtos
essenciais faltam lá no frigorífico na
despensa e vocês sabem exatamente por
exemplo tem que ir à mercearia comprar o
avaí
imagine por exemplo possa escoar com a
roupa dentro da nossa máquina de lavar e
ela inicia o programa e saber exatamente
o programa tem que usar qual a
quantidade trajeto ele não ser o que tem
que usar pra lavar eficazmente a copa
que vocês tenham lá dentro eu não sei o
que vocês acham disso mas eu acho que
veio antes só estamos aqui com prova já
amanhã e é preciso trabalhar para que
desista
isso porque com isso sozinha
a roupa é que é uma tarefa a partida
muito fácil eu acho que eu me chamaram
para camisola da fala da brincadeira mas
a gente também que vocês conseguem
sequer um hospital no aeroporto e
navegar facilmente sobre os pais muitas
vezes têm indicações confusas e fiz isto
por que vocês têm que passar nossas
matas onde ela interagir facilmente
completo você está em conseguir navegar
mas vai isso eu preciso falar em sexo
não consegue muito mais abrangente
adicionando da internet das coisas que
eu ia falar em certos responsáveis por
implementar um sistema de consciência
porque a file que não tinha
identificação muito princípio concorda e
destaca qualquer o último responsável
por uma das casas em vez de ensinar por
identificação visual como é o caso do
pálio placas emitindo moeda rádio e um
sensor passivo onu de caso não colocar a
vida imita a informação volta forma
simples uma prova de conceito dos anos
desenvolveu o produto e o que nós
fizemos foi desenvolver um protótipo
protógenes está a mostrar
do ponto de vista tecnológico que era
possível criar uma antena em base de
cortiça e que era possível colocar uma
antena em um sistema amplo possível até
faria funcionar em garrafas com bebidas
líquidas lá dentro está atualmente pode
ser essencialmente interessa para pôr
fim e vendedor se e em lojas de venda
nos hipermercados no sentido de
controlar a qualidade e fazer a
identificação e inventário dos seus
produtos mas nós estamos a trabalhar no
sentido de tornar tudo mais interessante
mesmo para os próprios consumidores
o próximo passo eu tenho eu e os meus
colegas responsáveis que trabalham com
interesse essencialmente três próximos
passos
o primeiro é continuar a trabalhar e
desenvolver o protótipo tornou
interessante para para uma aplicação
comercial externo conquista tecnológica
do ponto de vista do investimento é
conseguir fazer esse produto chegar ao
mercado porque não é importante sermos
empreendedores e criará naufrágio novas
violências e depois ao tentar sair do
impasse ideológico é continuar a
trabalhar essas idéias e continuar a
desenvolver tecnologia nesse conceito de
internet das coisas pra tornar uma
realidade
convida-se ir lá acima o café das idéias
e ver alguns dos meus próprios dentes a
funcionar
obrigado a votar